oh good i just know chin chin looks good
chin's been working out he's got his
blood work done his testosterone they've
doubled naturally which i don't believe
don't believe that there you go is that
my blood work no no but i'm just saying
i don't believe it's natural what do
they have eaten
yeah are they like just inject this in
your ass it's natural they gave me
clomid clomiphene
oh yeah that that masters are pregnant
alone okay and a bunch of other stuff
they're trying to restart your tests
yeah balls are going to start yeah they
want your testosterone to start doing
what your boss will produce that's where
your testosterone comes from so a lot of
times
your testes will shut down yeah yeah so
they're trying to uh ramp those bad boys
back naturally yeah they say it's
natural balls are heavy right now
they feel pretty good pretty normal yeah
but now you said your testosterone is up
double yeah
it's over a thousand something it says
it's it's over
the maximum or whatever oh wow so yeah
daddy's popping which i'm like i don't
feel any different though that he's read
like he said they'll take a month or two
now a thousand is cool you know what's
cooler than a thousand what 3 000. is it
really is that safe uh
i think it'd be cool for you to try out
my last last night i didn't take
testosterone but i had what's called a
deep tissue massage like a deep tissue
one i haven't had one i don't know i
don't know [ __ ] a year and a half i'm
on a plane you know that those fun don't
you love the planes we have to take two
planes where did you fly to though
okay so you guys there's no direct
because yeah it's happening you gotta
fly to chicago
in there yeah you'll wait and then that
chicago
daddy got home had a massage now did
they come to the house he went to like
massage he came to the house oh oh you
originally yeah now now um this is my
girl gina who works on our boy brian
ortega different people she's [ __ ]
great and she's a sportsman so she knows
some [ __ ] yeah she's getting into my
hips she's getting to my feet my calves
and i'm
you know feeling it it's a real massage
it's a real massage and i that is not
emotional daddy's not emotional but
i got done and i was feeling i i swear
to god and maybe i fell asleep a little
bit or something i started a
hallucinator i said do i think i'm
hallucinating on the [ __ ] she goes
you are it was weird i go yeah i feel
like i was hallucinating it was a weird
feeling i'm holding the baby i'm sitting
there watching tv
and i'm and i'm feeling
weird
[ __ ] i don't know what happens well
when you get those deep tissue massage
it releases a ton of toxins is that what
it is
right dude that's why a lot of people
have massages get sick obviously
that's why i've never had them that's
how your nose starts running
that's what happened to me yeah all that
stuff so and i'm literally going i feel
like i don't know if i'm gonna cry or or
i'm gonna start sprinting i don't know
what the [ __ ] was going on with me man
i'm watching um
i'm watching this french
tv show called la jeans where they
it's a family that sells luxury
stuff on the netflix doesn't matter
anyways so
and then i go to sleep
and i and i i had the most insane dreams
and one of them
was the most horrific dream maybe of my
life
i go to sleep yeah neighbors bro the
nightmares there was a demon woman in a
tree
and i'm standing like that and i can't
move and i'm looking at it she's in a
tree dude and i just see her take her
finger this long creepy finger creepy
finger and she sticks it in she has a
nail and she sticks it in my mouth
pierces my tongue oh my god was it
pelosi
yeah she pulls me and i'm getting my
tongue pulled towards her you couldn't
move dude i couldn't move and i'm
telling you when i said that well that
that dream lasted
17 hours yeah yeah you can't get out of
it i couldn't get out of it is
my girl said you woke up and went
like that well hard pass on the masseuse
now yeah i don't want those nightmares
i said she had her finger in my mouth
that was my she said my girl was like
what i scared the [ __ ] do you feel
better though after the massage so much
better yeah so much [ __ ] better
what'd you think of appleton
i loved it you liked it it had a blind
is it cute little towns cute little
decisions
hold on the town let's get let's see i'm
talking i'll talk about the town i'm
talking about the town there is there a
coffee shop there's no coffee there's
one then it's right outside that hotel
yeah daddy went to copper coffee yeah
yeah good stuff that's your own coffee
shop sure yep all good home grown
another place called tempest went there
i only need one yeah and you stayed at
the hotel right i need my coffee yeah uh
i had the gym in the hotel it was fine
yeah and uh it was actually kind of warm
kind of warm in wisconsin so did a
little walk here around the uh the river
there yeah and then wrote and performed
and yes [ __ ] great crowds it sounds
nice yeah the crowd the crowds are great
there and and conservative crowds jason
ellis got up and he has a wolf tattooed
to his head i love jesus yes and he's
fantastic and he told his stories which
are not for the faint of heart good
stuff but not for the heart especially
if i'm assuming if they're not familiar
with them it could be a lot well they
they it's a conservative yeah they were
all like okay wow did they laugh you
know
david lucas monster comic monster and
we'll go into some towns and you know
his material is
yeah it's great
there's nobody better as far as like in
your face like some polarizers in the
world are very conservative yep and
they're like uh uh in places you're in
oklahoma yeah that's when i got this
jersey oh yeah yeah we went and how's it
go his trump show is gonna crash here
no no yeah there's certain spots like no
sir yeah oklahoma's
concern
i went bad on uh newsome and garcetti on
stage on friday night my mom and my
aunts came to see me do stand up this
new bid on garcetti and newsom and the
crowd was tight on that stuff is that
right
oh we got new some fans is it possible
they didn't know this is going to be
oops it's going to sound comfortable if
they didn't know some garcetti it's
possible no they did you think no
because if nephew's dead silence all
good you guys don't get the reference
when it's oh
i'm like i went oh wow really oh wow
yeah oh [ __ ] they're pretty nice 14
newsome fans yeah interesting yeah it's
weird right very interesting my mom was
laughing i did a corporate gig one of my
first uh yeah my first corporate gig
yeah you should have those mr corporate
guys yeah those those are funny
well cause like it's it's like weird
obviously you've done it before but
exactly if i'm stopped doing them all
right no no no no no no listen listen i
i made for you though and it was fine
yeah but it's good money after yeah
exactly good money nothing wrong with it
but you can do it it's like no i was
like no they eat a dick but did they ask
no they actually didn't oh that's nice
yeah so
[Music]
they get like when it comes to material
they'll give you about
20 minutes of listening to it and then
after a while
they just want you to make fun of
everybody that they work with oh that's
what i felt i don't know if you like
that if you cause they they love you
you've done them they love like they eat
it the more personal well it's like
insane jay's wife has uh a retreat in
santa barbara every year actually here
during my birthday yeah and they always
bring a big comic that does he's there
that uh uh michelle wolf and jay said
nobody was better than michelle wolf he
goes she came here it's all these
business guys in suits everything and
they're with their wives and she came
out out the gate and she was like she
was like how awkward is it you guys are
thinking about your side pieces
she's like she goes she goes we're in
santa barbara i'm sure last time you
fellas were here you weren't with your
wives and jay was like
the guys were dying but he said like the
husbands were like trying not to laugh
yeah jay was like she was just told like
lit them the [ __ ] up wow she's such a
beast oh god that's one of my favorites
but
do you feel that because i'm you've done
them right oh yeah i i've got to taste
that because i i
said
i went i noticed that they they said go
bad on some of the guys if you can't
they always say a guy with a huge head
and i just i was talking and i stopped
and i was like now how am i supposed to
do my act and how am i supposed to
concentrate when that guy has a head
like that yeah yeah yeah yeah
i know around the eyes that's the
running joke when you die can i haul
your head out yeah your head could house
a family of four for real i was just
doing this stuff they were [ __ ] dying
i just kept coming back to his head yeah
like i'd do a set and i'd be like dude
your [ __ ] head is in the way did they
say i've gotten offers for corporate
gigs and then they give you a rundown
like oh make sure you brian likes to do
this yeah hey hey yeah i'm not so they
had like they're like brian applebee's
they have fun with that yeah i had a
really
who was it it might have been sagging it
might have been somebody who said to me
um i always feel like i'm being rented
when i do a corporate gig yeah i never
forgot that and i was like what's up but
some comics are but they but
don't get wrong they're all great people
they're all super nice
like it was it's a corporate gig yeah b
let's take a little break from chat
about you know birds can we talk to
dinosaurs can we talk about hair loss
because i'm losing my hair you know what
i was going to say something and i
needed some help you know i was gonna
get you for uh for my birthday which is
very soon yeah i was gonna give you the
gift of uh keeps keeps yeah they offer a
simple way dude a simple affordable
stress-free way to keep your hair but
you got to keep what you have so yeah
well of course i know a lot of men lose
their hair more than 50 million men in
the u.s suffer from male pattern
baldness i'm one of them you're not
lying dude so but i need i need
five-star reviews yep that's my friends
at keeps plus this low-cost treatments
are just 10 bucks a month
can i get a virtual doctor consultation
that's what we're going to do for you
man and it's delivered straight to my
door every three months right two door
prevention is key so you know we'll do
our best it's expensive i need low cost
10 bucks per month
that's right keep your hair up keep what
you got if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
fighter k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fighter
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that's
keeps.com k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
florida get your first monthly keeps dot
com slash fighter i wanna learn a
language i wanna learn a language and
that's what i wanna do because i wanna
travel and be one with the people dude
bro i need i need spanish my entire
household speaks spanish they talk trash
about me so you know what i did i got
babble dude babble baby it's fun it's
engaging all right
i do it while i'm driving a million
subscriptions yeah that's right daddy
and i use it while i'm driving to work
babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons for real-world use not like your
high school days babel's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go
other language learning apps use ai for
their lesson plans but with babel
lessons are created by over 100 language
experts
all right their teaching method
apparently has been scientifically
proven to be effective and babel you can
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german plus babel speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
pronunciation and accent and there are
so many more ways to learn with babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcast games videos stories and even
live plus 20 day money back guarantee
they're so dang sure this start your new
language learning journey today with
babel and right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you get
an additional three months free that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com use promo code fighter
that's babble.com
b-a-b-b-e-l dot com code fighter babble
language for life
now did you hey did you see me singing
on saturday on stage i reposted i
restored it i see you that's singing and
you sound great don't lie
he didn't but i didn't see it no i
didn't you didn't see it you're jumping
over you i told you boston
was obsessed with the video on my main
page or whatever boston dude
let's talk about boston for a second
he's he's his head is as big as yours
yeah he's huge yeah you got it i mean he
looks like an adult look at me right
there brian he has a real idea i saw it
i loved it
[Music]
but you know it's the same as all the
other
a bad way i'm videos saying
watch me jump in the air brian
no but but but chappelle you're acting
like i haven't seen hardcore concerts
before you haven't really i was never on
the stage when the crowmag's no we've
been out you weren't you weren't yeah
yeah i promise i did you want me to call
john joseph right now
well he got a new number
[Music]
but what i love is that just be proud of
your son is what all i want i love the
diversity of the crowd
he sent me he said this is a group text
i just put y yeah
well but did you ever see bad brains
back in the day yeah yeah so bad brains
what about tell me about bad brains
brian well
bad brains was so so bad
bad brains was
like
those guys who were they were black
and they played for white crowds okay
but bad brains bad brains was a
groundbreaker and i can't remember the
guy what was the lead singer's name hr
so hr had a meeting with i think warner
records are some huge records
and they wanted they wanted to take that
sense yeah they wanted to take them to
the next level they are they're like
like they're like whenever you hear like
they're in chili peppers or you hear the
cro-mags talk about they all talk about
everyone's
i don't know their music on the pictures
they look reggae yeah
they do have something that's like later
so you know they were just but
that is a hardcore band yeah that's cool
and also like still doing the way they
would perform crazy
softly but you know hr so he had a huge
opportunity to sign with uh with this
record label back when it made
everything
well i mean a lot of people famously
just he just didn't show up
he just said no i'm not doing that you
don't want to sell a soul
it's not even selling souls
it's like
what we talk about here it's like
they're in control of everything that
they do yeah when you kind of get into
that certain world
you got bosses they were the first
i've only heard i've only heard jon
jones talk about it a lot because he
knew those guys i think he wrote him
yeah he did he did but bad brains like
like like
john always said that with they were
kind of the first band or one of the
first few artists
who literally were way before their time
because they didn't have social media
yeah but even back then they were like
no
we're going to try to do this all on our
everybody
every anyone in hardwood would always
rage against the machine the same way
yeah were they with a big
because it's weird to be right against
the machine but then you have to wait
later no i'm not no no no no he's
talking about like i'm saying did they
do the same thing i think were they
independent
were they independent
i don't think i don't think there's no
way they signed with it like a major
like universe
there's no way
with their with their [ __ ] there's no
way yeah the easier way to do it is if
you go to their discography and it'll
tell you like if it's part of a major
label like it'll be like mca or
geffen or
whatever actually they might have been
part of uh
has pictures of mao in his [ __ ] um
but uh
no a lot of those bands i think he was
just like
i don't know they just
put rage against the machine record
label yeah yeah record
what records were on epic
i don't know but but bad brains but they
haven't put out a record it was such a
seminal band i mean they had i don't
know you knew about them well bubba
that's my generation
in new york that's all that you know
when you're friends with all those
people that's what they talk about those
people fugazi remember fugazi do i
remember from yeah oh that [ __ ] it's all
my generation yeah yeah no no no that's
that's fair epic travis scott
camilla cabillo french montana future
meghan trainor that that lead singer of
bad brains
like his performance like back in the
day was like like [ __ ] intense really
he would go
off on like one of the best were they on
drugs or no no really silver two i don't
know i actually don't know that much uh
the hr the lead singer of baptism
heroin i think later i don't think he
got a hair one yeah i don't know
something happened i know he i know he
was like homeless he's still alive yeah
yeah he is
uh what do you think they do now
not much
they might still tour go to europe and
play uh
no because he he had something with his
brain he had surgery on his brain or
something like that yeah suffers from
s-u-n-c-t syndrome a rare knight i think
he's also sort of i think he's also
schizophrenic excruciation yeah
yes he underwent brain surgery yeah
there you go he also suffers from skin
too that's tough yeah okay
like well shout out to hr yeah
but no it's it's fun it's fun doing that
[ __ ] though like i i do know i like
seeing when you do it yeah yeah you have
more coming up
i have my own band we're playing march
26th we're at in orange county is that
when you take care of schaumburg yeah
it's our first show
no absolutely not please don't i beg you
guys
all right unless you want to work for
free fellas
be you were missed during the fight
companion huh i missed you guys you
would have liked josh barnett i loved it
dude he knows history like i heard i
would have liked him too i love josh
yeah because
his name with the war master
yeah it came from a uh uh rock band uh a
metal band yeah yeah a metal band uh
boat thrower i think so yeah that's what
he said but he
was saying yeah very very smart guy
intelligent he lives out here yeah
hollywood oh but he was saying um
that one of the scariest things that he
was talking about me doing stand-up and
because he was like you're tougher than
me like you have bigger balls than me i
couldn't do stand-up he's like the only
one time i got on stage is some big band
that band asked him to get on stage and
sing and they called him out in front of
everybody so he was like i got up there
man it was he was like not for me dude
it's their it's nerve-wracking it
actually kind of is because you're just
like i mean it's not stand up yeah it's
not they want you to bring so much
energy to where it's like i don't know i
don't know explain it but it's yeah it's
it's a lot of different i would have
loved him
he's breaking down romania and then he
was talking about ukraine and russia
and then he's been in russia a bunch of
times
yeah he's probably treated very well in
russia that's what he says he's treated
like a king out there yeah
oh he's a big [ __ ] did you
almost fight him
uh not really we never had a contract in
place but people thought we didn't like
each other but we've always had mutual
friends yeah we'd be like oh you and
josh get it because he's a gear head he
loves cars wow okay he left cars in
whiskey just like me
dude so he has his black belt and
whiskey like the [ __ ] he was talking
about i'm drinking his warbringer right
now go get it but he uh
he has his black mountain whiskey in
cars and i said dude
you know i'm not a gearhead like you but
any car from like 97 up i know my [ __ ] i
can't you know
switch out or put on a turbo
supercharger and he goes you don't have
to man that doesn't that's not the
definition of a gearhead you're a
gearhead if you're you know balls deep
in cars like you are just cause i can do
it myself and all that stuff doesn't he
doesn't mean it yeah i feel like he deep
dives in anything
ever like you know he's recommending
books to matt and [ __ ] is he around your
age no how dare you no no he's 45 i
think yeah oh really yeah he's older
he's got a good sense of humor too he's
gonna fight for 25 years oh [ __ ] yeah
he's such a top three of all time yeah
it looks great for 44. yeah he's just a
warrior
he's born
that's a that's a dope name he has a
long beard now his nickname used to be
uh babyface ballard high school is that
in louisville kentucky no seattle oh i
think he was a wrestler in high school
yeah yeah one of the greatest ever do it
out there in seattle wow yeah
look at him that's a jaw it was in high
school yeah he's calling baby face and
then they switch it to war master war
master he's just such a good dude man
yeah he really is he was great on there
you know how it is you never know with
fighters right in my head i'm like i'm
gonna have to carry this thing but dude
he carried it i didn't have to do any
yeah it's funny how it got me thinking
about when you said um he said you're
tougher than i am like i think part of
being tough is being able to step out of
what your comfortable place you know
yeah taking chances yeah or just getting
get into a whole new thing it's really
really not easy very few people do that
most people have a but most of us kind
of like
yeah even though we have like the
feeling to want to do it but you have
that fear like
super scary yeah i don't want it i
remember one time that there was this we
had that situation where somebody was
trying to [ __ ] with you and i and i said
to them i go
i said listen you know he's not going to
do anything to you
he's not going to do anything but if you
get his attention
and he puts his attention on you
i promise you i promise you you're not a
[ __ ] tap not just it was a thing
it was a while ago but i remember and
you know what i'm talking about and i
remember i i remember i said if if
he's he's you can do whatever you want
yeah yeah but if
he has no problem stepping into a very
uncomfortable place and you do and he'll
take you into deep water where you don't
know how to swim i'm not talking about
fighting this was something no no yeah
no and and i think that that's that's
probably the definition of what makes
you tough and you know you were willing
to act you wanted to stand up you're
willing to do whatever the [ __ ] it takes
and and then you get really focused on
something because you have a thing and
things couldn't be going well better but
it's like
if if you get his attention if you get
his attention it's it's uh
it's gonna be well you're gonna be in
you're gonna get you're going to you're
going to grind them yeah no that makes
sense yeah you would have loved josh
though
yeah josh is josh and josh i think is
very comfortable in combat he's very
comfortable in conflict he's it's like
he it's i talked to him about it for a
little bit it's like he he feels like a
modern day samurai
he's just a modern day samurai he did
bare knuckle in poland yeah what the
[ __ ]
she's crazy
he's just such a badass and then i
actually didn't
hear on gracie yeah and i tell him uh
i was talking to him and i said when you
go out anybody [ __ ] with you and he's
like i'm not that famous dude so
sometimes guys well and he's talking
about it happened years ago these guys
uh stepped to him
and it was like three or four guys and
he goes you better go get more friends
and he said the guy was like what he's
like i'm telling you better go get more
friends if you want to step to this man
really like you have a good day
you imagine yeah yeah you got to get
more friends and then
he goes he goes i always try to
de-escalate everything goes and
obviously he's very his vocabulary is
fantastic yeah so to he elaborates like
basically he's like we're going to sell
this with violence if you want and i
also have my black belt name discipline
i have my black belt in it yeah so you
can do that yeah but he told the guy
goes but i'm telling you have to go get
more people
you're gonna get your neck dude but
imagine the
four of us are in a room and you're
[ __ ] with amigos how scared does your
baby go how many you come with four you
can go and get more people you'd be like
excuse me you know i hadn't i was like
okay man have a good night that should
be a line in a [ __ ] movie
you're gonna go near getting more people
i was in college i never
i'm in college and i'm with four of my
friends
and you know i'm the only guy who did
any kind of taekwondo wrestling around
yeah yeah but i'm you know none of us
were we were all [ __ ]
regular-sized guys and stuff and i never
forgot
my buddy starts the guy kind of cut us
off it was one dude he was probably 40
40 years old maybe maybe like josh 44.
and
we cut him off he cut us off we got his
words exchanged i never do this but my
friend's a smart ass
and he starts [ __ ] talking to the guy
like
yeah
and
the guy
goes oh really
okay well i'm gonna fight you
and he pulls up to us and he goes hey
[ __ ]
i've never forgot this i'm like this
yeah i'm always in a good mood yeah but
he was older and he goes you put your
hands up look he goes like this he goes
no i'm driving oh drivers
he does hate [ __ ] [ __ ] pull over
pull over right there i'll fight all you
yeah let me get that let us stop you
dude i was like this guy knows some [ __ ]
i don't know yeah awesome that kind of
confidence also he's a grown man and i'm
19. was just something about that like
you know what i mean and i was probably
seeing some [ __ ] that old dad stream oh
dude thick
just rough looking and i remember then
he kept pulling up going [ __ ]
you know you just yeah right
i
yeah
i respected the [ __ ] out of it of course
and i just was like even if even if we
do first of all my friends are all not
doing a thing so all of them were like
it's just me and him i'm like this guy
would [ __ ] he's gonna pick me up and
throw me on my head or kill me or
whatever it is he had something going on
but i it's true do you remember when uh
for where we i forget where we're at
were you with us when we i think it was
milwaukee and we were crossing the road
like everyone's crossing we're crossing
some guys you know you have to wait for
the the the crosswalk and then you can
take a left and there's just this dude
in like you know some ganks or a 300
seat christ or whatever where he thought
was a royals royce but i've never been
to milwaukee okay so he's trying to go
and then he runs it almost hits jay jay
hits the hood of his car what the [ __ ]
the window and goes
real
very clear not like shannon goes i'll
[ __ ] kill you
and then i went oh no and then jay was
like do something
[ __ ] do something and i i looked i
went what are you doing i went are you
ready for your mind there's no you did
don't you let him win yeah
there's certain key words like and i'm
not i'm not he wasn't like i'll kill it
very roll the window and then you see
this black hand go there we go
i'll [ __ ] kill you white boy
and then i thought well that's game set
match
let's just get to the comedy show go hot
head
[ __ ] deuce pull over i'm like are you
stupid hey are you stupid that guy
clearly means it you know what i got mad
at it this weekend appleton on crosstown
street this place called hyde or
whatever it's called and uh i i the guy
in a pickup truck i just kind of crossed
the street he was coming and he goes
like this right behind me i hear him go
use the crosswalk [ __ ] oh but it
scared me no but it was loud
i got startled oh wow that train
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't say
anything i just kept running but i was
like oh god he got me he he startled me
use the cross well i know i got started
gets mad at that i don't know i mean
people in small towns that makes sense
no just people who are asking i think
people in small towns apple because like
out here like
everyone's jaywalking yeah but like if
you're like in like you said appleton
those people are probably like yo use
that [ __ ] crosstalk nice people nice
people
uh a lot of trails though that's all you
can do so like hike and bike riding well
just yeah well like it's like a
like a walking i don't know that sounds
good a lot of people walking it was too
cold wait was that the hotel they said
it was warm earlier yeah yeah but not
not warm enough to just be strolling
outside oh see i was there i was there
in the summertime it rained at one point
yeah it's different yeah it's different
i mean i go to springfield missouri this
weekend you guys ever been there i it's
the blue room yeah yeah no but i i was
supposed to go and then i i couldn't i
thought i thought i was going to say
louis where do you fly into springfield
massachusetts but you're not expensive
they have a big
uh airport yeah oh it's a direct flight
no no no no no no no no no no no no
that's a springfield to boston no i know
oh i'm sorry and what's what club is
that the blue room you're doing it too
like later on i think
yeah you think in the wrong place how do
you have to get there
uh i'm flying what do you mean
two planes uh yeah i have to fly into
dallas then fly up it's a real tough one
for me
it's a tough one you guys ever been to
spring you guys know anything about
springfield no i i mean i like missouri
missouri's great ozarks
table rock it's great out there missouri
missouri's great cold
i know it's going to be i got phoenix
this weekend is great i got your oh yeah
my dad would be don't stand up tell me
my dad yeah my dad's going to come i got
him yeah phoenix i'll let you know what
night he wants to come have you done
louisville
no i thought you did no that's a new
club no i thought you did no i did uh i
did somewhere in kentucky you did he he
did uh lexington yeah
you know that louisville club's a new
club it was great
yeah the uh is that where they had the
derby
short flight you don't realize how far
nashville is
it's very southeast this is true because
you're on the east coast bubba in fact i
think it's east coast time yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah oh that's how we make
zany's though yeah that's great yeah
that's great last time when we were
flying home
we had hot chicken that weekend
and my man as soon as that as soon as
that plane took off oh yeah yeah yeah he
was like hey dog you gotta [ __ ] my pants
oh
was that not when we're not uh yeah
we're coming from nashville
you know because we went to like three
different hot uh hot chicken
restaurants jesus oh then yeah i mean
cat cat cake yeah
really hot one was like yeah we went for
the yeah we were for like the hottest
one i think yeah remember cat was in the
green room cat got twisted yeah yeah
yeah yeah
got me drunk drunk yeah yeah yeah
yeah
two shot wonder he's good yup yeah he's
the best yeah i like i love i love
nashville
that's true jeff guy's gonna be out
there he's gonna jump on the shows i
love jeff jeff facetime he's the best
he was in uh florida you know the spot
you're going to yeah jeff facetime me
and then um
rappaport facetime he was in pittsburgh
he facetimed me too he always facetimed
me for ufc fights
and i i i asked him every time you know
we always talk should do it i always
decline the call and go watch the shop
show
he's out okay
so i can't ask you about the fight did
you watch them yeah i watched no i got i
only got you watched them i only got to
see uh kobe and mazwell that's fine
that's all you really need to see oh
really yeah i wish i could have watched
the whole thing but i was like i had
chael sonia on this morning on shop show
right because he's really close with
kobe oh you did
oh yeah they hate each other this to
this day and and uh yeah that wasn't
manufactured they were you you were you
weren't surprised by that no really no
it's just hard to solve that russell
colby's the best welterweight on the
planet not named kamos yeah yeah but
that's what me and chill we're talking
about like he's in a weird spot so
you'll see
leading up to the fight and even after
like he's like oh fight izzy i want to
fight conor i want to fight um who was
saying that uh colby he's like i want to
fight um
is he you want to fight is he and then
no dustin he said then he called dustin
poirier after the fight and then dana
just keeps shooting it down and i was
talking to uh chael about it because
again he's very close with colby very
close yeah and he was like but think
about dude he's in this weird spot he's
the number one guy
that our sport really doesn't give a guy
a third [ __ ]
fight for a title so he's like he's the
best but he's not kamar usman so it's
like he's trying to get so he wouldn't
invite us
he's gonna have to win one more and then
get this man yeah it's just tough oh i
think i think he fights the winner of
hamzad versus gilbert that's what i was
going to say
and although
that's a fight that comes out fight with
him i i just
he's scared [ __ ] oh my god
that'll be a fight i'm really excited oh
wait what comes out that's the newer
guys
was fighting at 85. i don't know how he
gets down to he's very tall he gets down
he gets down to uh 70 which has got to
be a hell of a cut for him does he have
a cleft palate yeah yeah yeah okay okay
i know he is a [ __ ] salvage so before
he was this one type of dude he is he's
standing but uh lives in trains in
sweden yes and so there's all these
mythical stories about him in training
so his coach will say we've never seen
him lose around in training he's gone
with and you know our camp alliances
which is one of the biggest okay he goes
you know our camp in sweden like we have
monsters he goes with everyone
heavyweights light heavyweights
middleweights destroys everybody never
see him lose around and you're like yeah
all right whatever
but these stories keep popping up keep
popping up and this coach is like no no
no that those are all true
chael when i had him on the show he was
yeah i was actually in vegas at the uh
the ufc institute and uh hamza was
training there with gus finn um
tail a bunch of guys he's like they
asked me to come he's like you saw i was
going to come in and go can i bring a
camera and they're like sure whatever
you want to do hamsa doesn't give a [ __ ]
so
chael said he was going to go there
and he had to work for espn he's like so
i couldn't make it he was but uh when he
got done i
attacked somebody who watched it and he
was like hey is it true hamza it's just
that much of a beast and the guy
responded you have no idea god damn
i don't know who's gonna beat him uh i
don't either i don't bet against anybody
with a chin strap from anywhere like
chechnya
i don't know who else is in his um 170
colby
colby
he's fighting gilbert burns yeah wonder
boy's there it's a stacked [ __ ] and
burns ain't no punk
burns is no punk it's just a bad match
but i think kobe should stay i think
kobe should stay at 55. yeah after
you're here he's 70. no coconut 170.
they fought at 70. those guys totally
only fights the 70. he's not 55. wow
yeah he so he the reason
i lie i'm like
he wants dustin parry to come up to 70
to fight the super fight but dana's like
all right so you fight that then
what do we do with it where'd you go
from there yeah but if i'm kobe i'm like
well what am i gonna do yeah i'm not
obviously camaro's fighting leon edwards
next i don't want to sit around and wait
yeah i guess i'll fight the winner of
muhammad
or the winner of gilbert burns and uh
hamzad
so you know that's that's you just don't
have a
hamza uh burns is a fight yeah cause
also hamza as much as we're on his chin
strap and hairy nuts which i am we just
don't know yet but he hasn't fought like
the upper echelon guys and gilbert burns
the upper echelon guy he also we haven't
seen him in championship rounds we
haven't seen face diversity like we
don't
know
i'm i'm all in yeah i don't know who's
gonna yeah i i i think he gives
everybody what does that one is
including he's got that i think first of
all it's that russian sort of like
greco-sambo wrestling that a lot of guys
who's dagestanian
i think he's from chechnya actually but
it's the same thing yeah but he's
studying he's he's it's the russian
system right yeah and a lot of those
folk wrestlers and freestyle wrestlers
unless they fight internationally are
wrestling internationally don't haven't
seen a lot of those transitions that
chain wrestling it's really hard to keep
up sure but there's nothing better than
a guy's come up like him like he's
running
burns would be sick he's a good dude too
i don't know
he's just gangster
so before he was i was telling you
before he was in the ufc remember
connor's talking all that [ __ ] about
dagger standings khabib yeah yeah he
flew from sweden to dublin to beat up
conor mcgregor he was going to his gym
and was arrested by the dublin uh
security at the airport and was like
detained for like seven hours no like
you can't come here we know what you're
doing and then so they sent them back
home
he was like two and oh not in the ufc he
was just flying there yeah he's gonna
show up to connor's gym and [ __ ] him
yeah he's no he's he's those guys don't
play but yeah they don't [ __ ] they're
just those guys so it's like it's it's
it's a way of life where does jorge go
from here personally i want to see him
just be famous as [ __ ]
and make lots of money and we have to
worry about what he has to fight
yeah he just signed the third biggest
ufc contract ever [ __ ] not retiring
he's not ready for that
no it's not like he has damage either he
would have taken a lot of damage he
didn't take damage from that fight he
just you know he's such a no i could see
a conor mcgregor fight with that really
makes the most sense that'd be great
yeah you think that's going to happen i
do international fight week july wow wow
why don't they do the
this may be a dumb question don't hurt
me but why does he why don't they do the
diaz with all that there he fought yeah
he has i mean for the most part just
kind of beat him up yeah that fight i
mean yeah he does nothing deals with
take it but yeah i think i'm gonna do
diaz poirier
connor mozville that's what i think ds48
yep for international so what colby
calling out um fourier like vaporize not
that
weight level or weight no
he's not it so what's the point of
calling him out just that just there's a
super fight i'm trying to get money okay
kobe just wants fame and money yeah yeah
i don't blame him it's also like you're
there it's like what else am i gonna do
dude fight these young lions that come
through the rankings
he's got to be i think until kamaru
usman retires which he's grumbled about
yeah or like you know
did they fight again yeah do they do it
yeah yeah i think what's gonna happen is
in all
actuality i think what happens is hamzat
beats gilbert burns and then the ufc's
can go okay kobe we got one for you if
you beat him you're guaranteed a title
shot and then kobe would take it
kobe just needs some direction right now
it's just he's trying to throw all this
mud at the wall hopefully some sticks
and land on the moon
and i think dana's he might right if
home gets by this dude then you'll fight
arms up not gonna lie for the title that
makes sense sure i like watching him
fight who goldie fox yeah yeah i like
watching
he's incredible yeah he's incredible
it's like it's like cool to see i don't
know he's i don't know how his cardio is
so crazy
his cardio
how crazy his cardio is that good it's
not tomorrow's was better that's that's
even crazier
tomorrow can't run look at all the
muscles
too tomorrow is bad and easy does it do
rope doesn't do
these are bad
freak wow
so yeah so then
so usman just chills until no husband's
fighting leon edwards i think in two
months or so oh okay
what do you got on that now now now i'm
the guy the other guy but he doesn't
have wrestling i guess so it's a
different thing holland holland was he's
just physically so gifted oh oh yeah
kevin long ways
no he just got there right so he's
coming off two losses cut to 170 and
just got his first win and yeah he was
in some trouble yeah he was but no
that's fine he's got a ways he's got a
race he's not a vessel he's got a right
yeah no he's i love kevin holland he's a
beast but no like he's he's on the
conversation with those guys yeah
no all right jim what are you guys
impressive shy let's take a little break
to keep the house lights on because we
got to kick off 2022 with a better
checking account man no no monthly fees
it's an award-winning app called chime
and debit card it has no overdraft fees
foreign transaction fees monthly fees or
service fees with over 60 000
fee free in-network atms at many
locations like walgreens 711 cbs you can
access your money when you need it where
you need it i also love you can send
money to anyone even if they aren't on
chime fee free for you and no cash out
fees for them all right make your first
good decision in the new year and join
over 10 million people using chime sign
up takes only two minutes and doesn't
affect your credit score get started
chime dot com slash fighter that's chime
dot com slash fighter banking services
provided by and debit card issued by the
bancorp bank of stride bank and a
members fdic
get free fee free transactions at money
pass atm in the 711 location and at any
all point or visa plus alliance atm
otherwise had a network atm withdrawal
fees may apply sometimes pay anyone
instant transfers can be delayed the
recipient must use a valid debit card or
a chime member to claim funds talk to me
about peloton i know you got one i know
i know i know see these i know you see
these big teardrop quads i mean i'm very
happy with the problem i've got juicy
quads thanks to pelton dude i swear by
him i've been a member for six years
thick boy prez is my username on there
you can choose any can you like you can
actually choose new classes
music and the best thing is yeah the
pelton bike plus dude new ways to keep
your workouts fun motivating like boxing
and how about the new artist series
music selection what do you like pop
rock hip-hop
we got you covered man it's easier to
stick your goals when you keep your
workouts interesting pelton has a
workout for every day and every freaking
schedule de-stress from a long day with
30 minutes of strength 20 minutes of
cardio do a quick 15 minute total body
class before work what's up man stay
motivated
while having fun with bike workouts yoga
meditation dance cardio and more visit
1palton.com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
all right oh wait a minute hold on what
about that kid from arkansas who oh
mitchell nice mitchell yeah savage
badass yeah undefeated 15 minutes yeah
great kid wow what a great he's getting
[ __ ] because you know he's talking about
the government and vaccines and stuff so
he's getting a ton of she said i don't
know what's going on in ukraine but i'm
if you come to arkansas i'm going to dig
my boots in i'm going to fight for the
people i love them no that's not what he
said no no no no that's not what made
headlines no you're talking about the
post fight yeah no no no that's not what
coming in it was before that actually no
no he went on aerial and you know got
some trouble first oh he didn't mention
saying that no one's going to take his
guns away he would actually literally
die for it like i think his family will
say this
he was talking about the government and
how you know it's corrupt and vaccines
which i actually like because i like
guys with colorful personalities and
it's also like we want to be the nba we
interview the guy he's like you know we
train hard you shoot the ball it's like
yeah
[ __ ]
if you don't agree with them
that's the best it's so [ __ ] one of
the things that he said that was
controversial is that the you know the
las vegas shootings which was horrific
he said it was an inside job oh jesus
but the reason so his reasoning was
because
you know the government has been trying
to take away our automatic rifles
forever so they're trying to get do it
make give it a reason for them to be
like oh you can't have these rifles
yeah they think yeah it's a conspiracy
theory yeah they think there's more than
one shooter
with it yeah and then also he did it
right before that big law was passed
right like yeah it's a coincidence but
now yeah now that we know the government
and all this other stuff that's going on
i'm starting to open my eyes a little
bit open the door a little bit more
conspiracies none of that
shootings i don't because i don't think
that was crazy but yeah but
like look look at sandy hook with you
know that is yeah that's insane there
are crazy people in the world that that
fantasize and do mass murder mm-hmm
and those kids were younger kids that's
that guy that guy did that sandy hooked
yeah it was easy for him to do it and he
brought a bunch of guns up there i'm
surprised it hasn't happened before
but nevertheless
younger kids
they were like teenagers right no i was
a guy i thought i thought that was two
teenagers right
now that's called
nothing i could call it
was one guy there was one guy who was 63
years old yeah
shut down we didn't have to go to school
for a week because there's where were
you somewhere higher or higher uh i was
90 i was in eighth grade i think or
maybe ninth but i remember our school
shut down during that day because there
was something going on on the internet
even back then that the more schools
were going to happen so we just had the
whole week off it's kind of lit but
super sad right wow super sad that'd be
[ __ ] heavy we're watching it on the
news yeah cholera has some shootings
yeah oh yeah the [ __ ] one at the
movie theater yeah batman right it was
my mo that's my mama's movie
what's this what's this so there was
footage of drake putting a bet on the
colby mazvidal fight and he put 275
thousand dollars down for
mos vidal to win only for mos vidal to
then lose and people are blaming the
loss on the drake oh my god oh they they
always this is also well see how it's
for uh at br underscore betting
that's not drake's money this is a
promotional stunt i guarantee you drake
didn't put 275 of his own money up
guaranteed oh okay and then also the way
you can make the most money was by
betting on mazdal to win via finish
so this is just a
publicity stunt to get more people
betting yeah but also if you would put
on colby you know and what he represents
it's not going to make much headlines
this makes headlines it's good marketing
we're talking about it but drake didn't
put 225 on listen i love mosul at all i
[ __ ] love that dude i would not have
put [ __ ] a thousand dollars it's just
a terrible matchup okay it's you know
it's just
the the only thing i'd hope is they were
training partners so it's a little
awkward so mozball might be able to get
a flying knee or something but
stylistically when they they both bring
partners i wonder if
when they were training for that long
did one guy always get the upper hand
or was it always even we don't know we
don't know but remember they do
wrestling and sparring right i'm sure
there's patterns and all right and they
know what the other one's good at yeah
but the one thing you can't stop is
wrestling well and you're a two-time
all-american you're you're you know i
didn't know kobe's
that stud pac-10 oregon state yeah
said after the fight he's like
oh yeah colby's still a [ __ ] but that
[ __ ] can wrestle yeah he and russell's
house yeah yeah that's why i want him
for some sod oh yeah i can [ __ ]
wrestle
you know he did uh i think the whatever
submission underground just a wrestling
thing against uh jack or manson jack
kermanthen who's
180 he's a 185 huge see what happened to
jack i did not he spiked him on his head
so you never felt that kind of like yeah
was like i don't know what well he
probably what he was like that's not
oh dude just grabbed him and mollywood
yeah that's that's that
[ __ ]
i've never been more excited for a
fighter ever
so
if he loses if he loses on me so sad me
too yeah he's so excited he's [ __ ]
talking to dana while putting what's his
name into that he's like i thought he's
on him oh he knows what he's doing hey
here you go
and then one after he beats him and
kicks him in the butt joking around he's
like
such a beast
what else you have nothing at the office
this video is going around the internet
and people aren't sure what's happening
because they don't know if it's real or
not it's it's it seems like two russian
men i was just saying this is russia all
day and then there's a bear and it says
russia there's a black bear there's uh
tattoos there's guys with scott couldn't
be more russian he's got the russian
orthodox cross on his back they're in
jeans
but this is ukraine right who knows i
don't know
this is real watch the bear
it looks real as [ __ ] it does is that a
guy in a bear suit no that's a bear
that's a straight up bear
it's just an ab workout for homeboy
there yeah
that beer's like yeah get it man
[Laughter]
it is
i don't know
who works out with a few questions here
who works out like this who films
himself working out like this why is the
bear shaking the tree
yeah the way this article is written is
really funny they're saying that this is
the power of communism and starts
putting a bunch uh like random chinese
monks getting their balls smacked oh
yeah yeah let me see that chin
do they suck them up because you can
suck your nuts up no apparently you can
actually get them so hard that they look
like they're made of stone this guy is
out of this [ __ ] gosh i always
thought that fighting style was so
[ __ ] legit
i thought they could just [ __ ] up
anybody
man was i wrong that one is thick i know
that's really good for your testosterone
it looks like you turned the thicker
this is the dumbest [ __ ] ever
oh my
god
all right let's get these dicks ready
honestly not to be fair [ __ ] ever
[ __ ]
smaller
hey
what is this
what is that that's korea dude
damn it
oh
oh i think it's north korea the crowd's
fake right korea it looks like north
korea is a crowd fake i can't tell
because the way it's it's edited
what's he doing they're pushing that i
don't know what metal spot in front of
each other like to push each other's
necks
which would make sense if it's north
korea
which it looks like no no let's not do
this god they're just looking for any
form of entertainment
oh no don't do that
shut the [ __ ] up
it's not gasps like that huh christian
david blaine do that that's not david
blake hey man
this is some wild [ __ ]
wait there's more let me see
oh with his head ran right through it
all right there you go oh that flying
kick is pretty lit though
yeah
they hit their arms with a hammer oh
do they break their arms i guess not
dude how bored are they in [ __ ] north
korea look at that that is north korea
that's what yeah
[Applause]
this has to be propaganda i feel like
it's not a real crowd no so it is
basically propaganda it's trying to show
the world that how strong they are which
we don't really do they realize that
it's doing this
it's just a couple of the [ __ ]
yeah it's just doing the opposite in
fact america's like what the hell yeah
what
that's how you want to show strange
what's that one says these folks on a
different level
that's gasoline
oh i see this it's pretty dope
where's his pants
that's a car watch
what
they're just bored man there's a bomb in
that cloud but why is he doing without
any pants i don't know
white boys built there let's see this
one i can watch this can the fancy this
is dumb [ __ ] all day yeah i don't play
the music
it's just all white guys dancing what's
he doing dancing he's having a great
time oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh he can dance though here we go sort
of here we go no he can dance i mean
two dudes behind him
i like to get in the hat yeah yeah this
is what people do at raves now yeah
that's what that's like back in the day
they used to have the uh little break
lights and you get eight this is what
they call it shuffling yeah shuffling
yeah the black girl was like okay i know
yeah no you can move i mean i'm not mad
at it you're just taking a break selling
honda's modern day napoleon dynamite
yeah yeah i guess uh i'm
yeah all right bryan's not impressed i
just depressed
how they're having fun on the break
though
they're selling hondas bro i know you
see the [ __ ] we do on our brakes not
that oh we don't we also don't sell
hondas
be a tough game we would kill it though
we did i don't think so yeah they're
good cars selling honda pilots and ships
yeah we saw a pilot in the heart last
what's this
there was footage found of a teacher in
indiana following a student and slapping
him in the hallway i guess the teacher
and the student had gotten into some
sort of argument and as the student was
walking out the teacher actually
followed him down the halls and ended up
slapping
play that [ __ ] yeah i'd be the first one
at the school yeah
i hated sticking with you sure
tonight a teacher in india arrested on a
preliminary charge oh can't have that
that was a punch surveillance video
released by bowgo kid hit his head
appears to show a student in a hoodie
walking down a hallway at gemtown high
school in elkhart indiana last friday
moments later a male teacher is seen
chasing after him upon reaching the
student the teacher appears to grab him
by the backpack then this an open-handed
slap the school district
the student's head appearing to ricochet
off the wall the teacher appears to grab
the student by the arms before yanking
him down oh wow within seconds the
student seemingly collapses on the
ground the teacher walking away as
others attend to the student in a
release balgo community schools says the
student suffered visible injuries and
was treated by medical staff we're
unaware of what happened before the
recording
well it doesn't matter just don't
[ __ ] hit a kid like harm any student
will be quickly directly and severely
addressed wait he was getting involved
he was taken to jail
scroll up chin scroll up from me it says
michael hosten61 from indiana i was
taking into custody on thursday on uh
charge of battery yeah you can't have
that dude yes don't hit a [ __ ] kid
not show up at this school
let me just get level six felony not me
yeah that guy's five what's a level six
felony sounds pretty bad i don't know
yeah you can think level six any felony
feelings yeah anything level six lost
his mind
someone someone's in there daddy's out
of energy huh yeah uh no i just i i lost
a little energy i didn't i'm not didn't
lose my energy i got i don't know why
those karate videos made me embarrassed
oh
i got all still yes so stupid
i was just like oh my god man all right
that's what i expect out of chris yeah i
feel good though but then i like the uh
[ __ ] i like when he blew up the car
oh a riot broke out at a mexican soccer
league game and it pers i guess it was
so bad that they had to go ahead and
cancel the rest of the games for the
rest of the week didn't like 16 people
die or some [ __ ] they were injured i
don't know about people dying i'm pretty
sure
uh 22 wounded seven 44 people two oh
none dead
initial death toll of 17 which remains
unofficial unofficial but still 17
official report claimed 44 people that's
a real
gang busters yeah
oh [ __ ] they just
footage too
the game wasn't even over yet this is
like
oh wow they're just tearing that kid up
yeah i guess
it started out with a few fans and bum
rushing the field and then it became an
all out just riot
but the game wasn't over yeah it didn't
look like
i think the game is over
nothing good happened players aren't out
there this guy with a bat
yeah what the [ __ ] he's a champion yeah
he's such a girl's trying to he he's
trying to get his girl out of there it'd
be terrifying me yeah yeah jesus christ
man what am i gonna do without my
vexing league soccer now i don't know
i'm so disappointed yeah damn it that
affects my life so much
wish i could just
did we talk about it here the kane
velasquez was denied bail
uh
we didn't he just got dele uh denied
bail today yeah and says judge condemns
reckless actions and another thing that
turned out on his case is that he has
mark garagos who's supposed to be this
really really really high profile you
know he did michael jackson
for defense or prosecution defense
kane's lawyer and they're saying that
someone is fronting him the money so for
sure yeah i mean like you know i'm
guessing dana white or something like
that i mean someone rich
but someone i don't know
dude kane is a bona fide celebrity yeah
he can't walk down the street you know
for mexican culture he is huge dude yeah
yeah he's going to have tons of support
mm-hmm definitely intense support and he
has one of the best lawyers in the world
so
that costs a ton of money yeah tough
tough case right but so far he can't
even get bail right now yeah because
they're don't worry did they shine did
they set a court date i don't know about
the court date
damn wasn't there a gofundme set up for
him too i heard that but i looked for it
couldn't see any uh derek brunson set
one up they said he raised a hundred
thousand oh but he's selling shirts
that's in half of it yeah
yeah i don't know what you do i don't
know how you uh 50 grands i'm gonna do i
don't know how you [ __ ]
fight this though
well with that big lawyer you know
obviously yeah well but
it's really
april 12th
rammed a car
and off the road that's why they don't
even bail emptied your gun into it
because you're in you're endangering
other people's lives and now they said
speeding down the highway i mean there's
yeah the premeditated thing uh chill had
a good point on it he was like well with
his defense team's gonna you say it
wasn't premeditated like he woke up
absolutely and then went just insanity
yeah yeah he wasn't playing it four days
before but that defense didn't tell me
to eat that up yeah
especially with a high profile lawyer
yeah
because he's gonna do time no matter
what
premeditated is hard when
like if you had time to get in your car
get your gun drive
find the guy
chase him it's a lot of time
a lot of times if it's just like you
mama you attack somebody because they
did something or you found somebody your
wife in bed with another man
you know and and the insanity defense
you've got to be able to prove that they
didn't know the difference between right
and wrong or that they weren't supposed
to even though he doesn't have it i
would rely on ct
i'm sure his defense is all over
whatever you can do they're definitely
smarter than us probably figuring it out
i believe that sometime but not that i
bet you don't do that long especially
since the guy didn't die i hope not
everybody doesn't do that long
hopefully not
what else yeah hopefully not
let's see here
uh you mentioned this earlier brendan
that anonymous says they they
hacked russian tv services and they
would play the footage of ukraine being
messed up so russian citizens could
actually see what's going on oh so i
heard ukraine they're calling their
friends in russia and russia has no idea
how bad yeah yeah like wait they're
killing kids and bystanders like yes
like no they're not because they're
getting a completely different thing
yeah so on their actual their television
stations they're seeing all this footage
that's probably the u.s we've got no
they are anonymous yeah this is our
peeps and this message is from anonymous
they're doing the lord's work it's
pretty badass um it's pretty long that's
like two minutes he hasn't watched it
please can the fan see it yeah citizens
of the world
this is a message to vladimir putin from
anonymous
mr putin
the ongoing invasion of ukraine has
shown that your regime has no respect
for human rights or the
self-determination of your neighbors
in the past several days a full-scale
invasion has commenced civilian
neighborhoods have been bombed and
innocent people have been killed
refugees are fleeing the violence and
the population is being forced into
conscription by ukrainian officials
this is an ugly situation all around but
you are the instigator
you have criticized the us military and
nato for their occupation and
bombardment of the middle east which is
certainly a fair criticism but you have
shown that you are no better than the
imperialist governments that you
criticize and the whole world can see
through your propaganda
even the citizens that you are claiming
to protect are entirely against the war
and protesting across dozens of major
cities in russia your tyrannical
response to the russian anti-war
protesters will only spark further
unrest among the russian people who are
suffering the consequences of your
foolish actions
the sanctions will hurt your citizens
far more than they will hurt you which
is why the sanctions are not a proper
deterrent
now the most popular resistance will
come from within
instead your ambitions for conquest are
much greater than you are willing to
admit
if you continue on this path you will
continue to lose support among russian
citizens other countries around the
world will refuse to cooperate with you
and you will face unprecedented cyber
attacks from all corners of the world
members of anonymous have declared cyber
war against your aggressive regime
with numerous government websites being
taken offline in the past several days
a few downed websites is only the
beginning though soon you will feel the
full wrath of the world's hackers many
of whom will likely reside from your
home country
your secrets may no longer be safe and
there is a chance that key components of
your government's infrastructure could
be hijacked
now with the invasion of ukraine the
previous invasions of georgia and crimea
are starting to come into focus and show
a clear strategy for russia to recapture
key areas that were once held by the
soviet union the soviet union failed
many years ago and the world has not
forgotten the brutality of that regime
the people of the world will resist you
every step of the way
this is not a war that you can win
regardless of how powerful you think you
are
we are anonymous we are legion
expect us
damn you uh say what bothers me is the
usa
nobody wants to talk about this and i
don't know why the [ __ ] that we don't
see this
the us and
a ukraine for that matter but especially
us knew that this was people say well
they miscalculated and think he was
going to invade when they signed that
that sort of pact that agreement with
ukraine essentially saying that
essentially saying that they would not
stand in the way of nato membership
anyone who knows anything about
geopolitics knew that they were going to
put vladimir putin in they know he's a
he's this kind of guy
they know
so
they knew that putin was going to do
something drastic
why
because he had
he's not going to allow them to join
nato if
he allows them to join nato
they can isolate him the same way we're
isolating them now yeah so so the u.s
acts is acting all like what i'm sorry
but there are elements of the u.s
government that knew exactly probably
what was going to happen [ __ ] yes and
there was an article written by a
russian historian who talked about this
it's like you and and for that matter
you know that zelensky everybody's
talking about the lessons
and and ukraine
government knew
that this was an incredibly provocative
move
putin in 2012 said that the one thing
that was never going to happen no matter
what was ukraine joining nato
because that would be that would put a
western ally that is directly
in in opposition to russia on their
border i wonder how much anonymous can
get done too you know obviously they can
hack into the government well they
they'll hack into the weapon systems
apparently so apparently there's a whole
cyber attack on their so they're they're
these new rockets this artillery
all of that is controlled by computers
it's a whole different thing there's
also a lot of unrest in russia man oh
yeah but we don't you don't hear about
it no it's it's the whole thing [ __ ]
is a disaster yeah it's a it's a
disaster but banks are pulling out of
russia i like how netflix is like we're
not going to let you watch netflix yeah
russians like right it is a world though
it is a world where you put you're
putting your you can put crazy pressure
on a country it's true and well i think
i think actually the people in the us
that did sign that non-pact that that
packed with ukraine i think it was in
2000
god 2019 i came over i'll look it up but
um i think what they were thinking is
they were they're going putin's going to
do something stupid he's going to
overreach and his own people the
oligarchs and all those people when they
start losing all their yachts
yeah they're gonna somebody's gonna
somebody's gonna throw them out
that would be the idea hopefully and and
that could that could usher in a crazy
revolution in russia because everybody
in russia wants to live the way all of
us are living for sure they don't like
[ __ ] yeah they they're tired of
having a one crop economy they're tired
of having a small group of people own
everything most russians are like dude
let's we have all these resources and
this incredible population of people use
it yeah they want to be part of the 21st
century and right now they're not so
godspeed anonymous
what have you got jen
all right um good news
lighter note i am legend the next
chapter it's going to start will smith
and michael b jordan i guess they're
both going to be producing that movie
together as well same writer as well
for the next chapter you guys loved i'm
legend because i loved it i thought it
was good i liked it yeah i thought it
was really really good
you know taran uh dog dies yeah you know
what tarantula you know he's holding her
over here yeah oh yeah
josh goes out there yeah that's where i
my
last time i was with him but but terence
taught what everybody he's right now
he's teaching the new batman that guy's
playing batman he teaches every when you
go to taran tactical if you're really
serious about your career
go there because that's the hub of every
famous person you see them
counter roofs didn't you everybody
that's where countries learn everything
yeah and and taran said that the one guy
who had
more talent naturally off the bat was
michael b jordan interesting really when
it came to his eye his ability to see
targets and shoot that quickly and learn
that fast nobody liked him i was like
damn the second was that guy yeah what's
his name
the formula one racecar driver oh
yeah that's your brother's guys his
hand-eye coordinations nazos yeah that
makes sense that's cool
and i'm not in that i'm not in that i'm
not
some of them you
[Laughter]
yeah you got to do it a lot yeah
yeah
what else you got jen
uh this is for you brennan
i guess anthony mackie is going to be
starring in a tv live action
of that video game you guys were talking
about yeah
yeah holy [ __ ]
i don't know how it's going to work as a
movie i guess if we do like a tv
oh it's tv series tv live action yeah
well live action yeah i'd love a small
role in it
will arnett's in it too he's going to be
part of the show runners our directors i
forgot was
that game was massive it's just funny
how you guys talked about it last week
and it's now it's fair i don't feel like
we're responsible
you know
he's huge he's from wasn't he on
saturday night no will was a magician on
arrested development
was he also in uh
what's that ice skating movie jimmy will
ferrell yeah oh blades of glory
yeah he's the brother uh-huh aren't they
sleeping together in that and then he's
in uh that movie with dax shepherd where
he goes to prison oh let's all let's go
to prison yeah let's go to prison yeah i
love that movie yeah that's great
tell me what you're wearing with you
really yeah
someone sent this in i don't know how
old this is or knew this is but this is
apparently adam driver
not realizing that uh jared little is
not a girl oh he grabbed grabbed him all
like
so he has his hand around his voice
oh he was like okay why am i graham like
that that's very strange but they said
he realized he's not lady
gaga i don't know he's got giant hands
like jared let's like hey dude you feel
so disconcerting yeah i was like what
the [ __ ] even he looks at him too right
there yeah he's like hey can you get off
of me i'm not your girl man oh [ __ ]
jared leto's at the ufc fight yeah yeah
yeah he always does that outfit dude
yeah pretty dope
dude there was this there was someone a
fan that reached out to me that showed
me
this page of this famous artist and his
name is bob callum
yeah that's been forever you guys know
about that
don't say all [ __ ] like you just
discovered a [ __ ] dinosaur fossil
okay
have you ever been to the game of hot
seconds
guitar picks no it's been a while i
forgot about it
yeah and i didn't even know if he was
real he's not really good yeah but have
you seen his work like when i looked at
his work i was like wait it looks kind
of cool but then i see what he does and
i'm like why anyone here could do it oh
really wow
i thought he was good let me see you
draw jim
it looks cool but i don't think can you
draw
yeah i know you can yeah let me see his
art i think i remember liking it
so
yeah we've known about him for quite
some time we're fans
oh i didn't see these artists wait i
don't know who that is let's go let's go
to his website [ __ ]
go to uh
fine art
that is cool that is a cool first name
though i mean like i could do this
i'm a fan i don't know if you can do
that shin all right we'll see chin
that top left one's pretty lit yeah like
stuff like this oh that's dope that's it
oh my god that's good
you should do it
let's go to his instagram
something i'm not a hater i'm a truther
i'm i'm like honest about everything
kellen
you said a truther
that's so crazy
like when you see him do the artwork
that's the show
it's definitely artistic it's funny
let's see so can you do this brendan no
you can't
those colors would be such a mess i know
right yeah dude i can draw
i can't [ __ ] do this guys
this is like he's just literally laying
down it would be a hot mess at my chin
you know the entire i should do it for
you guys the entire painting would be
brown there's probably a technique he
has to like pouring it and all this
stuff you're joking i am not joking chin
you really don't think that's i'm not
paying i'm not hating it's i think it's
that's pretty badass
that's pretty the toughest thing would
be to build the set but i mean as far as
doing that i'd like to think about it to
think yeah
he found elaine that's awesome but i'm
just not like you know
that impressed i'm the fan i think he's
pretty cool too
now he's spinning it to it oh and then
what's he gonna do now
you're such a [ __ ] hater it's not
even a hater i'm just being honest what
he's doing even he is a work of art like
even this is artistic i like it it's
physical art yeah okay performance well
i appreciate it kellen job yeah we do i
think yeah
don't let the channel get you down i
think it looks cool i think that's
really good that's awesome he's super
creative yeah
yeah
shout out to the challenge i like how
chill was like you guys could do it
there ain't no way i should do that yeah
right
what else you got jen um anything else
you want to hate on
i thought this was a nice story
that uh
the berlin's main train station
always different families are welcoming
refugees into their homes to take care
of them that's good it's pretty cool man
yeah and i'll show you like a little
video clip here
what good people
are kidding me
what good people yeah yeah that's cool
one room two kids that's all that's so
awesome
supplies and everything
on the right side there's thousands of
2022
place to stay this is absolutely
european just like enter the building
and there are like thousands of people
actually supporting like and they say
they have like a saying in the paper in
ukrainian in english in russia
i would do it yeah it's just beautiful
um that's kind of it i think what was
the thing that said baltimore hardcore
any ukraine oh that's
your shell you know what i mean
someone sent the sin oh that's all but
this is basically chappelle oh yeah no i
know that guy
yeah i know him
that's you he's a beast
is he just guest starring or like you do
oh no that's his band
oh that's his band they headbutt each
other oh yeah they're called ended why
do you punch that kid i don't know
yeah he's dope this is this repel in two
years
no that's me on march 26th
oh he's taking his pants off there we go
well this music's just different than
what i grew up with yeah not my that's
that baltimore hardcore that's more
awkward shout out
is that it that's it you i i wouldn't
catch you in that audience my god you
you wouldn't come see me my band was
playing uh no is it like that if it's
right next door if it's right there i'm
gonna come see if it's no if i have to
go right in i'm going to go ahead and is
it is there an area i can be perched up
on a wall looking down don't get punched
in the face dude yeah it looked like
they're going pretty well i was i was in
a pit the other night or two weeks ago i
once saw this man turn style [ __ ]
amazing man no it was amazing bro i
haven't been in a bit in years
like i was just pushing each other i'm
not built for that yeah i'm not built
but also like i'm one of the big i'm
probably the bigger dude in the [ __ ]
yeah i don't want i don't that's just
not mine you
immediately that's like that's like the
number one rule whoever it's just uh
i just don't want to do that with my mom
i'll tell you what i wanted what you
talking about you did a stage dive yeah
see that's not your culture nope i did
that stage type i've done that twice
once in d.c
you didn't have the foo fighters
i'll tell you i don't i don't want to
stage dive oregon i was actually really
afraid and it didn't feel like anything
my buddy goes jumping in that crowd and
i was young and sold her and i was like
okay
lamours um yeah i don't ever heard of
him no sure haven't please let me get
out of here um but i uh yeah i'm talking
to him
after the pub talking about small talk
we're talking about our hardcore fans
dude yeah there are hardcore fans that
want to know about tell you what i don't
want to uh stage dive where anywhere i
wouldn't do stage you don't want to
stage dive uh
people move out of the way
and i'm so big
i'm so big they would catch you i don't
know
when that big [ __ ] does it yeah
and then you like move yeah too big
though
yeah
they move or they just jack your like
shoes
shoes yeah i don't wanna crowd dive but
i do wanna do stand up uh
hollywood improv once you only shop in
french is uh this wednesday march 9th
there are 50 tickets left shop and
friends let's sell that [ __ ] i'll be
the sixth sellout show in a row then
nashville tennessee is this weekend
thursday friday saturday all shows are
damn near sold out uh tickets left for
the late show friday get them right now
thinkboy.com or fatkz.com
and then chicago end of the month march
24th
through the 26th as such a fire outfit
for chicago um and then phoenix is april
14th through 16th you don't come out but
nashville chicago get it
get it
i see you in phoenix this weekend friday
saturday sunday sunday show then i got
louisville kentucky louisville comedy
club march 17 19 miami florida i'm
coming for you miami improv march 25 26
27. daddy's on the road every weekend
yes i am yes i am and you need to take
off the date that you're done already
right yeah yeah right now we're going to
do this let me send a message
and i will be in
[ __ ] [ __ ] pop in
springfield missouri all right at the
blue room comedy club uh this weekend
march 10th and 12th that's simpson
i don't think that's simpson's illinois
remember oregon
and then uh april 8th and april 9th
uh
friday saturday at salt lake city at
wise guys comedy club boom get em love
you guys thanks for listening bye